[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do you remember the harlem cultural
festival
of course we remember the harlem
cultural festival
they thought they had booked the ojs but
we are the ojs without the apostrophe
it's dutch
ladies and gentlemen
the oj
hello good afternoon harlem
um
i'm kyle with the k and this is my wife
of three blissful years gene with a jane
who likes musical songs
i can't believe this footage exists
this is a miracle i got the gooses
[Music]
butterflies and fairy tales
have you ever tasted two drops in the
club
i am an astronaut
skipping through the cosmos
we look so young
it's like looking at the children we
never had did you know the carpenters
didn't have kids either
well they were siblings
let's say every day
you will get your way
that's it
that was back when i had both lungs
those were the days
let's get this going oh
what are we doing it's not a song let me
hear you
clap your hands if you like pizza clap
your hands if you like cheese clap your
hands if you like extra sauce can i get
another napkin please clap your hands
with you like peter the song became a
hit
number 93 on the charts
in germany
and we went on the road touring
children's pizza restaurants slash
arcades it was the time of our lives we
got paid in pizza
i got diabetes uh and lost my foot he
did
this is definitely gonna be in the film
right
why don't you shut up
you